is Lucy letby a psychopath that is a
great question short answer is no it's
really hard for me to psychoanalyze her
because there's nothing to go on she
wasn't antisocial she didn't have any
trauma that we know of in her life she
didn't have any kind of hostility or
problems in her relationships with her
work colleagues there was there was
nothing kind of pathologically wrong
with her emotional makeup and there's
very little Clues to what her
motivations were but to answer your
question was she a psychopath obviously
what she did hugely lacked empathy
obviously she was she was manipulative I
mean she lied and she hid her actions
but I don't think that she particularly
was good at conning or charming people
so I don't think she had those kind of
aspect she wasn't criminally versatile
she wasn't particularly sexually
promiscuous so no I don't think she was
a psychopath for all of those reasons i'
I I can't I can't answer the question of
why she did what she did which is quite
infuriating for me